thank you very much
um
super glad to see all of you here and
very nice
uh when i first joined into it four and
a half years ago as a data scientist
like probably as some of you here are
i told my manager back then that someday
i would like to become a data science
manager
i was already a data scientist in the
industry for four years but i thought
that someday it would be nice to to try
to
use other parts of my brain as well
so fast forward four weeks my manager
come to me with three management books
okay shir you wanted to be a manager i
need you to become a manager now
yeah you see the intuit israel uh site
was growing the eighth i team into it
for those of you are not familiar is a
very big financial software company in
america it has a turbo tax and
quickbooks it does
it help people with their taxes with
managing their small businesses
with marketing their small businesses
with the mailchimp as well um
so it was growing
the ai team in israel and he was the
only leader and he needed help with
little leadership and that was my
opportunity so although i was a four a
month pregnant at the time
i was the last person to say no to an
opportunity and i took on the role
and i won't lie to you my needs shook a
little
but i made a lot of effort i learned a
lot i did courses i read books
and i'm happy to say that
we learned a lot and we were successful
we were able to grow the team from two
data scientists to 11 data scientists
and really move the needle on into its
fraud prevention as well as customer
experiences with the ai models we
developed in our team
and today
i came to share with you some of the
lessons we learned because i think that
in this journey we were really able to
crack some of the
code
of the
secret sauce of the data science
management
so whether you are a manager
of data science or an aspiring manager
or a data scientist and whether you work
in a startup or in a corporate like
intuit i'm sure there are some useful
tips you can take from this talk to
elevate your team to the next level
so um
we're going to talk today first of all
about what does it mean to be a
successful data science manager
and and afterwards we're going to talk
about the three pillars of management
and how we apply it
in data science management managing down
managing across and managing up what
does it mean when you're a data science
manager and how to do it in the best way
possible
um this is a little bit about me i
started my journey in the israeli air
force as a pilot instructor for
helicopters
blackhawk and super stallion where i
trained pilots for emergencies to to
operate emergencies on air and later on
i went work in two startups takadu and
blue vine to do help save water in with
to the world using ai and blue vine help
small businesses with their cash flow
from there i went to lead a i went to be
a data scientist in into it and as i
told you four weeks later i became a
data science manager um and then
grew my team from 2 to 11 in these four
years
in parallel to that i also had three
kids
uh daniel deren guy
and i'm also very active
in the data science and python community
i founded the israeli branch of pi data
yeah
and
i i'm very
thank you i'm very enthusiastic a public
speaker
i also founded the israeli branch of
women in data science and i'm the wiz
ambassador and i have a podcast in
hebrew it's called unsupervised it's
about data science in israel
um and i participate in many conferences
and i'm very very happy to be here today
okay so let's talk about data science
management
sorry it's a reminder to take my girl
from kindergarten
um
so what does a successful data science
manager look like so i'm hopeful we can
engage the crowd in this talk so
do you have any ideas what does a
successful data science manager look
like you can just say
anyone come on don't be shy
anyone
attentive okay
what else yeah
great okay keeping the t motivated
yeah
oh very very good
very good important able to communicate
the technical things to the higher
management to other levels
great so um i loved all of the things
you said
and and to me to say when what something
is successful is to be able to measure
it so how do we measure a data science
manager so based on my experience there
are two things you can measure pretty
well
one is how much impact your team brings
to the business how much value you
brings with your ai that you develop and
the second is how successful and engaged
is the team
um and the question is
uh how do we do this where do i spend my
time as a manager we mentioned there are
three pillars we have managing up down
and across where do i need to spend my
time this is a question that i used to
ask a lot in the beginning as a manager
and well the answer is it depends it
changes you have to be adapted you have
to shift efforts according to demand and
you have to step in when where you see
there's a gap and put your efforts there
and the most important thing and it was
also mentioned in the previous talk you
always have to be with the growth
mindset and if you didn't read the book
by carol dweck named mindset i really
recommend you to read it talks about how
anything that you go through any
feedback you receive you can use for
your own good you can use it to grow you
can use it to improve and besides
yourself as a manager you have the
perspective you see
the entire team and how it behaves
always be with the growth mindset and
think what can we do to get better
so let's start with managing down here
are a few of the basics we need to start
with management
let's start with the challenge you know
all you i want you all to think with me
what should we do in this situation
dana received a request to build a
machine learning model that would help
more customers make their transaction
through our product then is not making
progress as you would expect as your
manager
what would you do
anyone has any idea what what would you
do in this kind of situation your
employees not making enough progress
yeah
okay great start with asking her what's
her problem what's the problem yeah
yeah
ask her how we can help great
go through her a current progress great
anything else
yeah
that's a really really great question
and that kind of bring me uh to my
answer and the the question was do we
really know what is progress and what do
we expect
okay so this is one of the first thing
my manager told me
about being a manager you told me sheill
when you're a manager you have to give
your team
members three thing expectations
training resources so this really
connects to what what's your name rafael
so it's really connect to me to what
rafael said because the first thing is
pointing finger to myself and asking
is the expectation clear do i do do i
set correctly what do i want what do i
expect from dana to achieve
um so these are the three questions i
ask myself in this kind of situation are
the expectation clear does dana have the
training to achieve this expectation and
that you have the resources
required to achieve this expectation and
once i figure out all of these things
with myself and maybe with a
conversation with dana i need to adapt
my own management style this is very
important every person at every
situation needs to be handled
differently by their own manager so for
each situation i ask myself
where is that person now if a person is
just starting to do a task or a goal and
it's doing it for the first time i need
to adapt myself i need to be more
directive maybe give more a specific
mentorship to that person
but if this person has already some
experience maybe i need to provide a
little bit
less directions but more support
if if the person is more of a mastering
a task or a goal then i need to be more
of a coach and asking questions to
unlock insights and provide stretch
opportunities to that person
so it's very important to adapt yourself
as a manager
but what if the person i i did all that
i gave the expectation they figure out
the training the resources i adapted my
management style but what if all that
doesn't work and still the person is not
performing as expected so the next stage
would be to give feedback
and i have a mentee not in my company
she's also a manager in another company
and we talked about giving feedback to
employees and she told me she i don't
like giving feedback to employees i'm
really afraid to do so i'm afraid that
it will make them not engaged that they
will feel unmotivated that they wouldn't
like me as a manager
and i told her what are you crazy
feedback is the best gift you can give
your employee and i remind you again
what we talked about in the beginning
the growth mindset right
feedback is our opportunity to improve
to be better so we as manager we have to
use it to make our team be better but we
cannot just come to people and give them
constructive feedback on air we need to
build a relationship with the person we
need to get to know them really well and
show them that we really care about them
and that we want them to develop then we
can make feedback
really count and really bring the people
to the next level so now that we're able
to give
someone a feedback how do we do it so we
have a very good model called sbi
feedback situation behavior impact
so in our situation i would come to dna
teller dana in this kind of situation
when you are on a project and you're not
making enough progress
and your behavior is that you don't
share with me your challenges or not
tell me that you're not making enough
progress um the impact is that
um
we
do not
deliver on time our management our
partners are not happy with us and they
lose the trust in us um so let's work on
what can we do in the future so it won't
happen maybe we will have a certain
milestone in which you share your
progress let's work together on a plan
to to avoid these kind of situations in
the future
so this is an example so how to how you
would give sbi feedback and another very
important point about feedback is that
you don't only use it to give
constructive feedback but you also use
it
to give appreciation and to amplify good
behaviors in the team i use it very very
often with my team when someone does
something very good for the team like
for example someone built a tool that
everyone can use for better monitoring
machine learning models in production
tell everyone
in the team publicly i i give the
feedback um that wow this person
build this tool for us this is a great
example of winning together of bringing
contribution to the team that takes our
engineering excellence to the next level
um so by by sharing this good behavior
publicly i show everyone in the team the
example of the good behaviors we would
like to amplify so don't forget use
feedback also to amplify good behaviors
also when someone is
struggling and doing small steps in the
right direction it's also good to give
them positive feedback in that situation
in order to get them going in this good
direction they started
and so that was the basics of the basics
now let's go up one level
and now that we have the basics covers
how do we help data scientists grow so
of course feedback is an important tool
for that but also other tools we need to
remember that data scientists are top
talent right these people have probably
have masters or phd or learned a lot by
their own
they're regular to be independent and
perform research on their own and they
want to be creative so we need to
empower them we need to make sure that
as managers we give them end-to-end
ownership on the tasks they deliver on
their models we need to hold them
accountable for the results and and we
also need to provide them with choice
if it's possible you know give a few
ideas of projects and let them choose or
even let them come up with their own
projects
also with the directions of research we
need to let them choose on their own
which will keep them more motivated
and
something also very important to help
people grow is to get a to define goals
together short term and long long term
goals and i will elaborate in a minute
and also
we need to make sure we provide data
scientists with space for research in
order for them to be to be able to be
creative and innovative and and we need
to find the right balance between
research and delivery
so
how does how do we define goals with
people what we do is that each person
defines their own goals together with
the manager with the help of the manager
and we meet every month we have two
types of goals input calls which are
about deliverable for the business and
development goals which is about a
personal development and growth
and how do we set good goals we need to
have goals that define what do we want
to accomplish um and we need to align it
with the business goals when it's an
input goal
we need to have a measurable metric for
that goal so we would know when uh
when you achieve that goal how uh
you say we're successful and we need to
have some kind of a deadline or a
milestone for that goal so
we will know when to check that we
achieved it
um and besides the monthly checking also
in the end of the year when we want to
evaluate the performance of workers we
use that
goals that they setter themselves and
their progress according to the goal to
measure their performance and something
more that we do is to a we have a data
science rubrics for the team data sense
rubrics is by criteria that we
defined in our group for each level we
define what we expect for this level to
operate for example if you're a junior
data scientist we expect you for x y and
z but if you're a senior we expect you
for a w and v okay so um it's very
important also in related in relation to
the previous talk that was here about
diversity if you have a defined criteria
of what you expect from the different
level of data scientists in a team it
allows you to be more exclusive and to
remove the bias from how you evaluate
your team members it's also allow you to
remove the bias when you hire people if
you define the criteria by which
you uh hire the people and not just say
okay i like this person he looks nice i
will take him okay
um
so i really encourage you to work with
your team or with your company to
understand what do you expect from the
data scientist in different level in
respect to to what is important in your
company
and something more we do is career
conversation with long-term goal i every
six months i talk with my team members
about what do they want to do in five
years from now i send them these five
questions in advance and so they get to
to think about that about what they want
to do and then we have this conversation
and then i
talk with them about what are the gaps
and what are the things they need to
work on
in order to achieve their long-term
career goal we can come up with a plan
together of the certain steps they need
to follow in order to get there
and the last thing about growing data
scientists is about balancing between
research and delivery so some ways we
found a are good to allow for more
research and innovation to grow in our
team is doing periodical hackathons in
which we stop all other works and all
meetings and just code in a combined
groups
between the team and and uh
this is
gives room for a lot of innovation and a
lot of
of our great projects started from these
kind of hackathons of a few days just
coding and doing
ideas from the team
and we also have an ongoing a long-term
research track in which x percent of the
time we invest in in
developing a new technology or
addressing new a problems we don't
usually address
and and to help data scientists not to
get lost inside all this research and
all of these projects i encourage you to
work in small teams have plans to what
are you going to do define the research
period when does it start when does it
end and what is the plan and also define
a standard sharing milestones in the
review milestones for each product when
do we do brainstorming when do we do
model review design review peer code
review all of these time points when
data scientists are obliged to come with
something to the table and present
something may help them not to get lost
and make progress
okay so this was about the individual
level
what about the team level how do we
build a high performance a culture in
our team
um so first of all we have to have
diverse skill sets and experience level
um and encourage sharing and learning
and something more that encourages
belonging in the team is to define what
is the identity of the team and even
come up with a name for the team for
example my team's name is oz the data
wizards of us and you can see here the
small logo
we have here we even have a sticker for
the laptop i don't know if you can see
it here but it's on my laptop
yeah
and we define together the vision and
the goals for the team so this is very
helpful for the team
to be motivated to know what team do
they belong and they are also well known
in the organization this is the oz team
and this is their delivery so it must be
very high quality
and also we have all kinds of ceremonies
and standards we have in the team
like the ones written here so i
encourage you to also think what should
be your team standards what are the
ceremonies your do you do with your team
in order to make sure you deliver things
in the highest standards like what are
your monitoring requirements what is
your project playbook
what are the metrics you want to measure
about engineering excellence
[Music]
and so a little bit about our weekly
team meetings something i always try to
do as a manager is to be very
transparent with a team and from my own
share my own lessons and even failures
with the team and what i've learned this
encouraged the team to have
psychological safety in those team
meetings and really bring them to the
table and let them be able to share from
their own
learnings and perspective
and we have an open agenda in the team
meeting we have a google doc and each
team member can add their own items to
the agenda so of course they are shy to
do so in the beginning so what i do is
in the one-on-ones i have with them on a
weekly basis
if i see something interesting they have
learned and they have done or they or
they have some challenge they need
some ideas about i encourage them to add
it to the agenda or if you i even add it
for them to attend that to the agenda
and then we use the team meeting to
consult to each other to learn from each
other and to share
the best practices and learnings and
also something very cool and interesting
we do in the two meetings it's called a
rainbows and butterfly
and what it means is a is a ceremony
that in the beginning of the team
meetings each person can say thank you
to another person from the team about
something a nice or good that this
person did for him or for the team so
this started team meeting with a really
great atmosphere and it's also a great
opportunity to amplify good behaviors
within the team
and something more that we do within the
team is the quarterly retrospective
planning so
this is a ceremony in which each of the
projects in the team define for the next
quarter the from two goals from this
project for example we want to move this
business metrics from x to y in this
quarter this is what we evaluate we
would achieve and the different team
members present the goals to the project
to each other it is an opportunity for
them to learn from one another and also
ask questions and advise and contribute
and it is an opportunity for us as a
team to do prioritization by impact
because we know for each project what do
we expect
from that project to happen where do we
expect to achieve so we can put more
resources in projects that we know that
would be more impactful by the from two
goals we have this is data-driven
decision-making which is very important
to be inclusive and to be to have the
right decisions
and and after we have this prioritized
plan we build as a team we share it uh
with the partners in
in the company and also with the
leadership so we create and align
prioritize roadmap which is very
important for transparency and to
achieve the support and resources we
need from our partners and leadership
so this all was about managing down
and what about managing across so i want
to ask you once again when you are
working with people in your company
which are not data scientists
like
engineers or
product managers or analysts or
different other managers in the company
what are the challenges that you have
okay so can someone uh
oh that's a good one yeah expectation
management yeah okay what else
yeah
what the x and y
x term
you want to explain so why but then you
explain x and then you solve the wrong
problem oh that you don't understand
what problem you're solving
right okay yeah that's a very good
problem yeah yes
oh yeah that's very good yeah
figuring out the responsibilities
perfect what else yeah
oh very good understanding that their
priorities are not necessarily our
priorities what else
oh we are and we're taken as the
technical guys and can give our opinions
on other things because we know only
about the technical stuff okay these are
all great things and they're i i felt
all of these too so i understand you
guys and i made some cartoons to
show a little bit about the some of the
regular uh conversations we have with
people around us this for example is the
data scientist and this is product
manager so the product manager would
usually ask why does it take so long
right and they asked why do you need my
help just do it and why don't you just
retrain your model or i want 99
accuracy
and the data scientists might feel but
well what the data is so noisy and it's
not relevant to solve this problem at
all
or what is the relevant business metric
we want to measure
and or what's the problem we're trying
to solve right with someone said this
before
um
so all of this can happen and all of
this probably happened to some of you
and so here let's dive into one of those
challenges for example we have a pm and
that we are working with and he wants us
to deliver a solution with 75 precision
but due to the limitation of our data we
can actually only achieve 50 percent
precision
so what can we do in this situation any
ideas from the crowd
yeah
okay challenge but
what else
challenges yeah
oh great idea change the scope somehow
yeah
okay
suggest to iterate okay okay yeah
yeah yeah try try to start with
discovering what is even possible with
this problem right yeah
very good try to understand whether
precision is even the right metric okay
so let's continue in this situation well
this is kind of a crucial crucial
conversation right because we are
only able to give something to the
product manager and he's not happy
because he wants something else from us
so in this kind of crucial conversation
i really recommend you to read the book
crucial conversation it's really good it
talks it describes how to behave in this
kind of conversation when your palms get
sweaty
with conversation when you know it's
going to be hard and how to approach
them so this is just a side
recommendation and and besides that um i
encourage you to first of all listen
okay what does the pm really wants right
is this even the right problem we are
solving or is this the right metric we
are aiming for precision maybe something
else can be achieved with in a different
kind of solution
and and also try to understand what's
really possible and maybe demonstrate to
the product manager well maybe um you
you have some kind of a benchmark you
can show from a similar problem well
look this is only what can be achieved
in this type of problems okay so you
can't ask me to go that high
or provide some kind of upper bounds
which is some kind of a mathematical
proof
and also maybe we can try to ask for
more data maybe it can help us achieve
better results
and
so this is what we can do at the point
of time of their conflict but what can
we do
to proactively avoid a conflict like
this with partners
so um what we did
is we tried to talk with our partners
about how do we work together we try to
as you can see we try to achieve for
world peace
between the ai team and all the partners
teams
and by talking we are investing in
creating trust and alignment and this is
a link to a blog post i wrote about it
that i can share with you later
um
and what does it mean um so basically
what we did is we sat down amy and my
partners the product manager the leading
analyst the leading engineer all of the
management team and talked about how do
we work together and then we wrote
together a document called the project
playbook and the project playbook
basically defines what do we do when we
deliver ai products to production
how do we start how do we finish what
goes on in the middle what are the
different stages who contribute and who
needs to approve each stage and how how
long do you do we expect each day's each
taste
stage to take and so we wrote it
together and we defined that the success
metric for this kind of documents is to
achieve zero conflicts with our partners
to solve all of those problems we talked
about that we have
so i encourage you to try to sit down
with your partners and talk about not
about the specific project but in
general how do we want to work together
and how do we see our joint work clarify
the expectations as someone said before
and so here is some of the things we
discussed and that are included in this
playbook first we defined a project
prerequisites
uh what do we need to even start working
or start exploring an ai project we need
to define a customer problem
and we need to make it clear for
everyone to make sure we're not solving
the right we're solving the right
problem and not something else and we
need to understand what is the ideal
state and we need
for this problem to be significant
enough to even invest data scientists
because as you know data scientists
machine learning engineers all of these
people are very expensive resources we
need to make sure we're investing these
resources in something that really
counts for the company
we need to make sure that we have enough
available relevant data to solve the
problem and that we have committed
partners people that are working with us
on the integration and the development
so we won't develop something that won't
even get to be called by anyone
and we need to make sure that a simple
solution was already tested because we
don't want to go and solve a problem
that can be solved with just a basic
business rule right so what do we need
all the efforts for
so these are our project prerequisites
and for the rest of the playbook we
wrote it guided by d4d it's a principle
that we use at intuit that represent how
we innovate at our company so first of
all we have deep customer empathy we
started really deep understanding of the
customer problem by
doing follow me homes which is ceremony
which we talk with the customer and
really understand their problem deeply
to be able to define it correctly
we go broad and then go narrow we try to
look for many many ideas to how to solve
the problem and then narrow it down and
we do rapid experimentation we don't go
and develop something many many months
and then go out
to the sun but every few weeks we
iterate what we already have to get some
kind of feedback and see that we are in
the right direction
so um in the playbook we have different
stages the first the very first stage is
to identify the mission team to deliver
the project because data scientists are
not enough we need to have
engineers and product developers and
product manager and analysts and we need
to start meeting we have we need to put
in the calendar a weekly meeting for
this project in which we discuss
the problem what we are solving the
progress the plans and we keep on
aligning on these plans
in this mission team we write together
the customer problem and the ideal state
and this is the format of the customer
problem we use it into it which
basically says okay what is the customer
problem we're solving what is the
benefit we're trying to achieve
and and
what kind of improvement would it bring
to the business what business metric we
will move and how much will we move it
so this is all very very important also
to align the expectations to understand
these things from the beginning
we need to understand the business
metrics and the suitable business
metrics that we're aiming to move
and then we need to define some data
exploration period that would help us uh
to that would
give us time to explore the data to
actually understand do we have our
prerequisites
is it enough time there is there enough
relevant and sufficient data to solve
the problem and what is the potential
that we can achieve so if we go back to
our challenge from before with the
demanding pom we need to from the
beginning say our potential where can we
even get to so in in order for later not
to have the pm say okay but i want 75
decision but this is not even possible
so from the beginning do an exploration
and say okay this is the highest we
we think we can get
and after we have some initial
exploration and research we align on a
roadmap
for the solution to be delivered and we
keep reiterating the solution as we said
with the product manager to get a
feedback
um
so here are some more tips on working
with partners very important for any
data scientist or for any manager first
of all we want to listen we want to
invest time in building relationship as
a manager i meet with all the manager of
my partner teams to have a direct
channel to to them to get their feedback
on
the
on the progress of their team on the
behavior of the team if they are happy
on working with us and if they see some
challenges that they are not happy about
we also want to make time to learn the
business to really help us not being
just the technical guys and someone said
here but people that actually understand
the business and be able to contribute
to it with
our data and insights we want to
understand the priorities and challenges
and that will help us help the business
um and we want to define the projects
from our partners eyes and not just from
the data science side a ice and by their
metrics by the business metrics that
they look at
next thing is to have transparency at
all stages so as we said we have
recurring project meetings
and and for these meetings we also send
meeting summaries if there are important
action items for everyone to know about
it's very easy that everything is
transparent in the meeting summaries
and we use those meetings to have
constant alignment on the roadmap we
always look at the roadmap so everyone
will know when do we expect things to
come out
and the last thing is that we keep on
working to improve our collaboration by
doing retrospective sessions with our
partners to learn and we update our
project playbook as we go because
there's always things we can add
give credit to other people on their
work
when the credit is due we have this
mechanism in intuit called spotlight of
recognition in which you can recognize
the contribution of someone to a project
so i encourage you to think about ways
to give credit to your partners
on their contribution this will help you
speed up the process of delivering your
ai projects by giving credit to people
and we need to we encourage you also to
work on your long on the business long
term vision and see how the insights you
have from the perspective or data
science
data science to give
to give to the business a long-term
strategy
and and i also encourage you to invest
in educating your partners about what is
ai and how does our work look like and
bring them more into the details so they
can understand your side of the problem
as well and also do some fun stuff
together that's always helpful
um so uh two more important things about
the playbook and there is it's a big
document i can share a later also a the
blog i wrote about it and before we go
to production
we have a model sign-off process in
which we share with all the stakeholders
that the model
relates to them and the
results from the silent
release of the model or from the a b
test so everyone will know exactly what
the model is going to do
before it's turned on
we share with everyone the dashboards
the business dashboards as well as the
performance dashboards
with all the metrics and and we create
all the relevant post-production
communication channels for example we
have a channel
in a slack
to ask questions about the model if
people are not sure about the model
results and we define some kind of an
incident management pro process for the
model
and after going to production of course
we need to have monitoring with all the
dashboards and alerts we have to look at
business as well as engineering metrics
in this monitoring we have to
define what are the conditions in which
we retrain the model because otherwise
the pm can come after a few months and
tell us well why don't you just retrain
the model now and i will just say no but
it wouldn't give anything so we need to
think together in which condition we do
a retrain maybe below some threshold or
maybe in some condition where the data
change drastically so i really encourage
you to think about all of these things
and define them in advance once you
deliver the models
you might also consider to build an auto
retrain pipeline if this is a very
important model and the data changes a
lot
and i also encourage you to do a
retrospective after delivery to
understand what can we do better for the
next time
and
continue meeting about this project even
if the model is already in production
it's a very important model now right
it's working it's
answering some a question is solving
some use case we need to see it's still
on track even months later so continue
to meet and monitor
the model together and see that everyone
is happy with it
so the last part and don't worry it will
be very short just one slide
is about managing up to our leadership
we talked about managing down managing
across and now managing up
what does it even mean
so first of all managing up the first
thing about it is to understand how can
you help your manager succeed
because as a manager this should be
your primary goal you need to make sure
your manager is successful your manager
is happy and well appreciated because it
all comes down back to you if your
manager is successful then you are
successful your manager gets resources
and interesting projects you get these
things um and the very important to
define and share the vision and scope
with your team it will help your manager
represent you with the higher leadership
and give you everything that you need
and to align the work your team does to
the company goals so everyone would know
what does this ai really contribute to
our company
and
it's very helpful to communicate the
team plans and also communicate the
achievements we did in the past we used
the quarterly planning sessions
to to do that we invite all the
partners but also the leadership so they
would see our plans and they would also
see
all of our achievements
um and we as managers also need to find
opportunities to share the teamworks and
let the team members share their work on
their own
it's very important so everyone would
know all the great stuff that we are
doing
and something more that i do and many
people are very surprised by this i
collect feedback actively i have a
google doc in which i just copy paste or
write down when people give me or my
team feedback and i share this google
doc with my manager once a month so my
manager would know how with people in
what does people in my company
think about my team and about me and
how well are we doing this is very
helpful for the manager to see that
think about it
and and
all of this basically is an investment
in the future of your team
making your manager happy making your
managers think that you're on track and
that you're delivering good things for
the company will help you get more
resources get wrecks
and get new projects which are impactful
and interesting and aligned with the
vision of your team
so to summarize the data science
manager's role is basically to create
the platform for the team to succeed and
grow
and we do that with three things
managing down
encouraging growth innovation and
building a high performance culture
by managing across
creating trust and alignment with our
partners creating the right processes
for the project to succeed
and managing up
sharing and communicating with our
manager the vision and achievements
of the team and by that investing in the
future of the
team
so
thank you very much
and i will take questions now
thanks a lot shir
so
the most upvoted question uh is actually
a lot of people took pictures of your
slides would you mind sharing them
somewhere
uh sure yeah i can i can share the
slides somewhere and maybe pycon has
some kind of platform for that i'll have
a it has a question i guess you can
update it in the description so i think
you can might find it then in the
description just of this talk yeah and
and i guess there will be some kind of
video right shared in youtube
so you can also use it from there but
i'm i'm happy to share the slides also
you can you can email me if you want and
i can share the slides with you
so do you think technical knowledge is
inevitable for a good data science
manager oh that's a great question i
have so many discussions about this with
people and
i think it kind of depends on which
level of management you're talking about
if you're a first line manager and you
manage a team of data scientists
directly and not manager of data
scientists i think that technical
knowledge is crucial
but i with that i i think you don't have
to be
you know
the the most experienced data scientist
in your team to be a good data science
manager you need to have to be good
enough data scientists to understand the
work to understand the challenges
and of course you need to be a good
manager and invest in all the things we
talked about so it's a kind of
combination and as you go up the
leadership ladder so the details of
course
of the technical parts matter less yeah
great
so the next question is how do you make
sure research track time is not used as
buffer that is always used for origin
tasks
that's a great question and actually how
we implement the research track is not
always by five percent or or ten percent
of the ongoing task it is sometimes like
a quarter that someone takes to research
uh something after for example after a
big delivery someone would take a
quarter now to just research a new
direction so this is also you know more
effective way to deliver it um and
something else if you if you do use it
as a 10 percent or 50 track then you can
make sure you just block someday in your
calendar
to do some concentrated research work
so that's a tip i always give my people
but it's basically a
a question of discipline you know how
much you enforce yourself to to really
apply it yeah
yeah thanks so what do you think should
be the policy for firing people for
example netflix has the mentality that
good performance gives you a nice leaf
bonus
i didn't understand the question
to be honest i'm sure i can repeat it
okay yeah
so for example
sorry should the mentality for
holding someone in the team let's think
strictly on a performance base
be off
if you are
we keep going on the team only if you
are very very good performance so the
example from netflix
and then
low to medium performance should leave
the team and then you would
enforceably make them leave the team
or should you just keep low performing
the team until they leave
um well
i think that in general i didn't have
the pleasure yet to fire people
unfortunately um but i think that you
don't want low performance performers in
your team because they affect badly
other team members because if someone in
your team sees that someone else can you
know not do much and stay in your team
then it reflects on them they and and
also they might be dependent of this
person works so in general you don't
want low performance people in your team
and if someone gets to the point when
he's low performing then or he she's low
performing then it's the obligation of
the manager to communicate the
expectations to this person and reflect
to them you know their current situation
give them feedback and give them
consistent feedbacks a few times and
document the process and if after a
you know x times of consistent feedback
there is no improvement then yeah this
person should be fired because you know
companies should in the end should
produce some results you can't just pay
people for being low performance
um
i hope in the death answer your question
how much should that be
so sorry how much should
does define low performance for you
for how long and like for how much for
them six months
usually most of the companies that i
know of have something called pip that
is performance improvement plan which i
think is about
three months or four months that someone
has to be communicated then it's in the
situation and that's it get an
opportunity to to get improved
but even before you get into the pip
situation your manager should be
transparent enough to give you the
feedback and to help you improve and i
think that if a person really wants to
improve and really
suitable for a certain role then he or
she will approve but maybe this person
is just not suitable and could find
himself better in a another position or
another company so maybe it would be
better for for him or her to to to leave
if if they're not able to perform
thanks i think we have time for three
more questions maybe so what book
influenced your thinking the most on
this topic
that's a great question because as i
mentioned i really love books i read a
lot of them
i think the most basic one is the
effective manager so if you're starting
to be a manager i really recommend you
to read that one
and another one that was also you know
mind-blowing for me is multipliers which
talks about how we as manager and we are
in general as leaders of anything in
companies um need to
not always not be the smartest person in
the room but help others
be smarter so because together when we
are all working together we can reach
much further
and not just you know make yourself be
the best on account on the expense of
other people
thanks
what's the biggest mistake you made when
you started out as a manager
um
well
i i did many mistakes
[Laughter]
uh one uh one mistake we did was
actually to take on a project i was not
a manager then i was just starting
leading
being a data science lead but afterwards
a transition to a manager with this
project
and we started working on the project
with a company that would it wasn't
clear
it was an anomaly detection work in
security and it wasn't clear who would
actually use
the result of the anomaly detection
system and i think maybe some of you
also familiar with this kind of system
you know someone comes to you and say oh
we have a lot of data please do some
anomaly detection from it because maybe
there would be some security breach or
something like that um but no one really
has the tools or maybe the times to
actually consume
the alerts this system brings out so
my lesson from that is to make sure that
if you write some systems someone uses
the output it gets out
thanks
one last question so
i think it's easy and hard to answer is
there a tension between time spent
developing goals making plans and
reviews etc and time spent doing applied
data science work
uh
probably mean as a manager right i guess
so yeah
yeah well of course and i remember
myself in the first two years being a
manager always you know on with the
tension with the boundaries of how much
hands-on work should i do and how much
would i invest in management and i think
it really depends on where you work and
how big is your team because when you
work in a corporate and you have a lot
of
you know a bureaucracy and a lot of
management
stuff that you need to do then you have
less and less time for coding so as the
team grew i think in about seven people
i understood that i can't be much
hands-on and the best use of my time
would be to invest in more of long-term
planning in developing my team members
because that would be the most effective
investment for me as a manager and i
found myself doing hands-on work mainly
in hackathons which is i mentioned are
very very important for me
great thank you very much let's give her
one round of squads thank you thank you